people have to be able to hold two
thoughts in their head at the same time
you can believe that people have very
tough circumstances and that we
as a society have a responsibility to
give
opportunity and hope to people no matter
the circumstances they came from
and it then on the other hand that
people still have some responsibility in
some personal agency despite
rough personal circumstances right four
years ago hillbilly elegy was a
well-regarded memoir
now with its 2020 netflix adaptation the
work has become critically panned and
the subject of endless controversy
critically panned but widely enjoyed by
audiences the book's author jd vance
joins us today to answer the question
what the heck happened in his book jd
wrote about his upbringing in the
appalachian regions of kentucky
and the rust belt area of middletown
ohio a look into the history and values
in this area of the country
was recommended by mainstream outlets
and cultural leaders in mass
for insight into the plight of white
working-class people that impacted the
2016 election
the praise was short-lived however when
the nearly unanimous edict came down
from the media that the trials of
impoverished white americans were
insignificant and should be ignored
in our conversation jd tells us why his
story fell out of step with postal
elites
in the netflix film adaptation season
director ron howard tells jd's story
with much of the political sensibility
and value of the original work
not in the adaptation it's just not a
political work despite that
nearly every major left-wing
journalistic outlet the guardian box the
atlantic vulture observer new yorker
have ripped the film apart jd and i
analyze hollywood's and legacy media's
frenzied relationship with hillbilly
elegy
we look at the culture of poverty jd
grew up in and the interwoven role
government plays in it
and how conservatives can connect with
the appalachian and rust belt regions of
the country moving forward
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special today's show
is sponsored by expressvpn don't let
others track what you do keep yourself
safe
expressvpn.com ben just a reminder we'll
be doing some bonus questions at the end
with jd vance the only way to get access
to that part of the conversation is to
become a member head on over to
dailywire.com become a member you'll
have access to all of the full
conversations with
every one of our awesome guests jd vance
thanks so much for joining the show
great to see you thanks for having me so
for folks who haven't read hillbilly
elegy which of course was your
huge best-selling memoir three million
copies sold became sort of the talk
of the country for a solid six months
there what is
sort of your personal story the book
really is a journey through your
personal story and then i want to get to
sort of the socio-economic analysis that
you do in the book but what's your
personal story
yeah so the basic story is i grew up
in a midwestern steel town like a lot of
folks that grew up in that area
very strong cultural connections to
appalachia because there was this
massive migration of appalachian people
in the post-war era especially
into the town that i grew up in it was
pretty successful middle-class town
the industrial decline hit it pretty
hard jobs disappeared
drugs moved in sort of a lot of the the
sociological things that we associate
with the modern industrial midwest
started to happen to my family and the
story is is sort of how this combination
of
cultural social economic factors really
influenced three generations of my
family my grandparents
my mom and her siblings and then and
then my generation
and kind of eventually things sort of
worked out for me i ended up going to
yale law school
i have a nice job we now live in
cincinnati and we have you know sort of
a normal a normal happy family
and it's sort of what i try to do is
sort of take
some of the lessons from my own life and
infer based on the sociological evidence
sort of broader narrative about what's
going on and give people a real sense
not just statistically what's going on
in some of these communities
but via my own family some insight into
what that actually looks like what it
feels like and really sort of immerse
people
in a broader story so i want to jump
into a rundown of appalachian culture
with you right now some of the positives
some of the negatives
first let's talk about how old family
memories can be the perfect
holiday gift okay so out in my parents
garage they're a bunch of old film reels
a bunch of vhs tapes they weren't doing
anything with them
we had them preserved digitized this is
what legacy box
does they're a safe affordable way to
digitally preserve all those home movies
and photos that are currently trapped on
dated formats like vhs or film with
legacy box you can reclaim all the
priceless footage
you haven't been able to see in years
and the service couldn't be simpler you
use their kit to safely send the moments
you want preserved
their team then creates a digital
archive by hand and you receive your new
copies
stored on the cloud thumbdrive or dvd
along with all of the original media you
sent them
with their tracking system you can
monitor every step of the process so you
always know your originals are being
taken care of over the past 10 years
legacy box has helped close to 1 million
families restore and protect
their most cherished memories i know
they did it for my parents right now
they're offering 60
off that's the best deal of the year you
can have everything preserved at once
for a fraction of the regular price
once you have the digital versions you
can relax knowing they are secure for
generations
don't let those memories just fade into
history instead
make sure that you get everything
preserved buy a legacy box i did it
myself for my parents it was a fantastic
gift
from me if i do say so myself they've
expressed their appreciation and all
your friends and family will too
go to legacybox.com shapiro take
advantage of this limited time offer get
off go to legacybox.com shapiro save 60
while supplies last
so let's start kind of with appalachian
culture for folks who don't know
anything about appalachian culture
uh you know in the united states we tend
to focus on cultures of poverty that
exist in sort of racial minority
communities more broadly in the media
but you talk at length in the book
about appalachian culture what are the
sort of positive aspects of appalachian
culture and some of the negative aspects
of appalachian culture that come to the
fore
yeah i mean one thing is is that
appalachian culture is is very
influential in the broader country right
so there's this interesting book called
the united states of appalachia and a
lot of other folks have written about
this that
because it's such a big region of the
country because it's sort of sort of
important
in critical american moments you know
john brown's raid on harper's ferry
civil war stories
there's this way in which the art and
culture and history of appalachia has
this sort of broader sway across the
country
and that that's sort of one of the the
things that i'm kind of teasing apart in
the book a little bit
but but like at a high level and it's
always you know tough to generalize but
i'm
i'm going to try to do so you know i
think one people are very patriotic
they're very proud of their country
they're very proud of their hometowns
they're proud of where they came from
very resilient and very loyal and so
it's the sort of place where people
don't take
lightly to insults especially to insults
to their family you know people like
malcolm gladwell have you even written
about that in that dynamic in
appalachian culture
and it's a place that's really attached
to the land and the things that people
have done on the land so
people talk about coal mining for
example as an economic force is
something that people do
you know provided good jobs and good
wages for a lot of people but if you
actually talk to coal miners there's a
real
pride in the sense that their jobs
weren't just meaningful jobs
but they also powered the american
industrial revolution that they provided
you know the the sort of the core raw
material necessary for america to wage
and win world war
ii and so there's this weird combination
of like pride in the land
but also real pride in sort of the way
that people have used it and manipulated
it over time
uh they get you get when you talk to
people i think you know the flip side of
it is that they're
you know like like a lot of places there
are a lot of downsides and i think
you know one of the things that's always
been true is you've had higher rates of
addiction
in appalachia that was true 50 years ago
when the drug of choice was alcohol
now of course is different drug of
choice which has much more substantial
downsides heroin
carpet and all other synthetic opioids
there's definitely a sort of tradition
of course not of everybody but there's a
lot of people who have experienced some
significant element of family trauma
or or childhood chaos and that's of
course one of the significant parts of
my story so
you know depending on the statistics you
use 30 40 of children in that region of
the country
will have experienced substantial
elements of childhood trauma and chaos
uh by the time they grow up and this you
know sort of pride of place
i think has a very positive aspect to it
but also can mean that people are a
little
insular they don't like when outsiders
come in and try to investigate or even
to help
and so there's this sort of combination
of real self-sufficiency
but also resistance to people supporting
and helping them
uh which has all of these sort of
complicated factors right so they talk
about the war on poverty which
was in some ways started in the mid
1960s in appalachia at least as a
marketing campaign
and people both on the one hand you know
feel a certain
um attachment to certain programs that
have helped them you know access
healthcare and so forth
but also a real resistance and almost a
shame at having access those programs in
the first place
and you have all these complicated
dynamics going on at the same time and i
try to capture that
a little bit in the book yeah how much
does religious observance
play into appalachian culture because
obviously tim carney's written a lot in
alienated america about
you know sort of differences in areas of
the country
and uh very similar populations acting
very differently based on religious
observance
yeah so it's interesting because it's a
very religious place right and i talk
about this in the book that growing up
my grandma was a very religious woman
you know we had portraits
uh very strong christian faith we had
portraits of portraits of christ all
over the house we had bible verses and
bibles laying around
we talked a lot about god in the bible
but in a lot of ways it was more
de-institutionalized than you might
expect
given how powerful and influential the
faith is and so it's a place where
people
profess the christian faith very
strongly but where church attendance
rates are actually lower than you might
expect given how many people in the area
are christians
and so you have this combination of you
know a lot of
obviously a lot of very powerful a lot
of very strong and important churches
but also a lot of people who have very
strong christian
faith but are sort of disconnected from
any real faith community and i think
that's an important part
of understanding the region because
people are very religious
at the same time there may be more
isolated from
a traditional church than you might
expect just if you ask
you know do a gallup poll and ask people
how christian they are and compare that
to religious attendance rates
it doesn't tell the whole story of how a
lot of folks you know whether it's on tv
or radio
very often get their faith more through
that channel than through an actual
church
you speak in the book about how
economics plays into all of this
uh and how the sort of transformation of
the american economy from a very
industrial based economy
uh and originally an agricultural based
economy to a service-based economy
really hit these areas of the country
hard how did that impact the places
where you grew up
one of the things that happened of
course is that
you know and i think this is a mistake
folks on the left often make right they
look at this area and they say well if
people just had more money if there was
less poverty if there were more
resources everything would be fine
and of course there's an element of that
that's true more resources certainly do
help material poverty is of course very
hard
but if you look at the actual income
numbers adjusted for government
transfers like a lot of people are
actually doing
as well today as they were 30 or 40
years ago
what's really different is that the
fabric of work and community provided by
good work has sort of disappeared right
and so you know in my grandparents
generation 50s and 60s middletown ohio
most of the workers in that community
they didn't just have a good job and a
good wage which is obviously important
but they had work that was that was
proud right they liked doing what they
did and they were proud of it i remember
talking to my grandfather
we'd see an old car in an old you know
sort of used car parking lot
and he'd say you know armco steel he
worked at armco steel built that car
like i know that car and he was proud of
that fact
but it also provided a real sense of
community right i mean there were there
were sort of
labor unions and other institutions of
work that existed
you know that just don't exist in the
modern service sector economy and so
you know sort of i know sort of labor
unions are controversial in conservative
circles
i tend to sort of be more pro-union we
can talk about that we could not talk
about that
uh but people i think always miss the
the the thing about labor unions is not
just that they were sort of economically
important to a lot of people it's that
they were actually useful as a sense of
community
and when you when that when that sense
of community sort of started to
disappear then you had a lot of people
feeling more isolated
and that's when that as you call it a
culture of poverty starts to take over
and really starts to influence and
affect how people build their lives
so let's talk about that culture of
poverty because obviously uh
your mom particularly gets sucked into
that uh you talk about in the book
uh the fact that she ends up being
addicted to drugs and how this affected
your childhood so how does that
transition happen
from you know more of a solid
middle-class
industrial base uh to a more
poverty-stricken
uh largely uh well not largely but at
least more
addicted population you know it happens
in very subtle ways right and
you know one of the arguments that i
make in the book is that sort of the
seeds for this dysfunction are already
there right a lot of people had tough
lives right my grandparents came
from very very deep poverty of
southeastern kentucky coal country
you know my grandparents lives were in
some ways much much more difficult than
in my life certainly um and so you know
in some ways people already kind of
came from pretty chaotic circumstances
there was this way in which the
community sort of worked in the 50s and
60s my grandparents certainly had
chaotic family life it wasn't perfect
there were a lot of issues with it
but the community more or less held
together and there's this way in which
when the good jobs disappeared and
people started going to church less and
there was less of that community
infrastructure that the seeds that
existed started to take over right and
so you had people
maybe you know addiction was there but
it was suppressed a little bit if
somebody got addicted
to alcohol if somebody was a really mean
drunk then the community would envelop
them they would help people get
you know get up get off the drink they
would some ways very
aggressively help them get off the drink
i mean this wasn't always like oh we're
going to come over to your house
and help you stop drinking and get you
the treatment you need sometimes it was
like a dad
talking to the kid who married his his
daughter saying if you don't stop
drinking i'm gonna shoot you
right but but those those ways of
community infrastructure
actually did kind of help hold things
together
and what happened in the 70s and 80s is
those good jobs started to disappear
as some of these broader sociological
trends started to sort of
become more overwhelming is that that
just stopped happening that when people
were really miserable when they were
really unhappy
there wasn't anything to kind of pick
them up and help them and so
you know you saw rising rates of
addiction you saw rising rates of
childhood trauma and abuse
and of course that becomes a
multi-generational thing and one of the
things that i try to really
get readers to understand in hillbilly
elegy is is the way in which family
dysfunction
is not just an immediate reaction to
sort of economic circumstances or
whatever else is happening
it can very often take on this
multi-generational life and so
you have families like my grandparents
generation that sort of held together
when the community was working
but by the time that my mom came around
the community wasn't working
you had these sort of really traumatic
moments from people's childhood
that were still very much with them and
consequently
family life started to fall apart in a
much more obvious and much more
substantial way
so in a second i want to get to this
sort of debate uh on the right that i
think is really fascinating between sort
of the libertarian answer to this
and the uh and the more uh economically
interventionist
answer to this uh which have been
provided by by different sides of the
of the debate and we've had those
conversations a lot on this program with
folks ranging from oren cassin to tucker
carlson that's kevin williamson
on the other side we'll get to that in
just one second first let us talk about
the greatest gift the greatest gift of
all i'm talking about steak from omaha
steak so
i'm a special person that means i got a
kosher omaha steak and let me tell you
this thing
it's so juicy it is so tasty i mean it
is just
magnificent because of omaha steaks
makes fantastic
products omaha steaks it is over 100
years old founded in 1917
still a fifth generation family-owned
company truly the definition of the
american dream
now what sets omaha steaks apart from
everybody else not all beef is good
enough to become an omaha steak
their fifth generation owner bruce simon
still buys all the beef
it's his high expectations for quality
that are the foundations of their great
steaks
then they age the beef longer than most
for at least 21 days
this makes it flavorful and tender and
juicy i cooked one myself it's
unbelievable it costs them more to age
than that long it is absolutely worth it
and finally
omaha steaks will vacuum seal and flash
freeze their steaks super quickly that
helps maintain the texture and flavor of
the steak
they lock in the perfection it is why
they say that frozen
is fresher than fresh if this 2020
holiday season feels like it has been a
long time in coming
make it worth the wait send them the
perfect gift and send yourself something
special
bring families together for a delicious
omaha steak holiday feast that deluxe
griller's assortment includes a vast
variety of entrees
sides and desserts and right now you get
that mouth watering package plus
four free burgers and a free digital
meat thermometer at an exclusive
price available only to my listeners
that's a discount of over 50 percent
head on over to omahasteaks.com enter
code shapiro into the search bar i'm
hosting just steak it's a guaranteed
fantastic gift
don't forget when you order that deluxe
griller's assortment you also get four
free omaha steaks burgers and a free
digital meat thermometer with my code
shapiro
at omahasteaks.com it's a deal you're
not going to find anywhere else
all righty so let's talk for a second
about some of the solutions that have
been proposed
to some of the sociological and
socio-economic issues that you talk
about in hillbilly elegy before we get
to your personal story
i find this stuff fascinating because it
really has broken down into a sort of
fascinating internacion debate on the
right uh on the one side i would say you
have sort of oren cass and maybe tucker
carlson
who have suggested they're a bunch of
people they're not going to move uh they
want to
live and die in the town where their
grandparents lived and died the industry
is gone
essentially we have to come up with some
sort of subsidy in order to rebuild
community economically outside in
tucker for example on this program on
the sunday special suggested that we
should
ban for example automated trucking so as
to preserve
truck driver jobs because jobs have
meaning and we don't want
even if it lowers the price of of
shipping and creates new jobs in
different sectors we have to make sure
that people who are capable of being
truck drivers
can still drive trucks and then uh live
in the areas they want to live in
uh oren cass of course is it has has
pushed a much more interventionist view
uh with regard to international trade
he's pushed tariffs and subsidies in
certain areas
and then on the other side and you have
folks like kevin williamson i'll admit i
tend to be
more on this side too and that is okay
well if the areas are
hollowed out politicians have a lot of
ability to make you false promises about
how they're going to bring jobs back to
to these areas and
make these areas flourish again but
politicians have a very poor history of
being able to do that
uh bringing jobs back to impoverished
areas simply through the force of
redistributionism government or
subsidies
uh and so maybe the solution is that you
actually have to pick up and move but
that cuts against some of the cultural
influences you're talking about
in appalachia particularly so is there a
happy medium there where do you come
down in that debate
well i mean i i guess if if we're
drawing the distinction i tend to be
more on the orin
and tucker carlson side of that debate
though i i do think that
uh it's important to sort of remind
people these problems aren't
all economic right and um you know so so
if i can i can sort of give a little bit
of credit to
you know if you're if you're casting
your lot um on that side to your side of
this debate
i mean i i do think that we often forget
uh that there's this really complicated
interaction between economics and
society right and so
um you you can't for example say
that if the goal is to eliminate
childhood trauma and to rebuild stable
families
that we just need to provide good jobs i
think it's a really important piece of
the equation but that's
that's not all of it a lot of times as i
talk about in the book you're talking
about like
the the the effects and the symptoms of
multi-generational
poverty of dysfunction of chaos that are
showing
up in these communities and if you think
you could sort of wave the magic
economic one and fix that i
don't think you can that said i do think
the economic piece of it is important
especially if we understand that the
economy is not just the way that people
provide for themselves materially
but they also sort of need that
community that comes along with a stable
job and good work
and i also think at a fundamental level
we have to meet people where they are
right so it's one thing to say to to
people well you've got to go get a
u-haul you've got to move to where the
economic opportunities are
that's fine for some sub-category people
i think some people are going to want to
move
but if in reality a lot of people don't
want to leave the homes that made them
where they are maybe they're willing to
move a few hours away maybe they're
moving
willing to move 45 miles up the road but
they're not willing to sort of drop
everything and move from west virginia
to san francisco i think we just have to
accept
that's how people are even if kevin
williamson may not like that that's how
people are
that is a fact of life and so we also
have to if we care about people i think
all of us do
we have to accept that we have to try to
rebuild some sort of
some sort of real economic and
manufacturing base
all over the country at a sort of
broader level to kind of cut away from
the geography of it
i tend to think that on the economics of
this
that a lot of libertarians under
appreciate
how important a manufacturing base is
completely independent of whether you're
trying to help people or they're trying
to rebuild communities or some of these
other
you know more social consequences that
we're talking about so so
um the the u.s trade representative bob
lighthizer i think has
written and spoken about this in very
interesting ways and one of the
arguments that he makes is that we have
this economic supposition
that we could disconnect the making of
things from the designing of things
right that we could design all the
things in america
we could make all the things in china or
malaysia or mexico whatever the case may
be
and that that's sort of the natural
evolution of the economy right
america would be the more advanced
economy where we make we designed the
iphones
china would be the less advanced economy
where they manufactured the iphones and
eventually we'd reach a new phase of
development
where china was designing those things
and we were designing something new
and i do think there was sort of a
fundamental conceit there because if
you're
not actually making things if you're not
actually working on the logistical
processes the supply chain interventions
and innovations
then you start to lose and atrophy your
ability to make things too
and so there is this way in which uh the
the
there was a sort of arrogance about how
we could disconnect the manufacturing
side of our economy from everything else
that i think is important for us to to
sort of recapture
some capacity in manufacturing and
designing
um you know we haven't lost all of it of
course we've definitely been more
de-industrialized than
i think pretty much every other western
economy except for maybe the uk
but we haven't lost all of it we still
do have a pretty powerful manufacturing
base that we could build on
i think in the process you're going to
be able to provide more good jobs to
people
and if i could say one final thing i
knew i threw a lot at you there and i'm
happy to sort of go down any direction
but i do think you know there's this
weird conceit that's on the left and i
haven't seen it on the right so much
even the libertarian right which i
appreciate
that you can just sort of easily reskill
people into new jobs
very quickly right and so you saw i
think rahm emanuel made a comment about
this on some national network a few
weeks ago that what we're going to have
to do is just go into
you know suburban rural ohio go into
west virginia and teach all these people
to code
and you know one i think that's like a
pretty bizarre view of human nature that
you can just sort of easily do that
that's that's not an
easy thing to do to transition people
from one skill set to the other
but i also think it sort of mistakes
that that
one of the reasons we had a very viable
middle class in this country for so long
is that we did have a real manufacturing
base right if people can't just learn to
code if they're not just going to pick
up and move to san francisco
you might not be able to save every
small town but i do think that if you
have a more stable manufacturing base
you're going to be able to have a more
viable middle class economy
which i think is just really important
for political stability for economic
stability
uh for for growth and innovation
downstream it's just really important
that we not
give up on the idea that we're going to
have manufacturing jobs there's been a
lot of talk about this
from obviously trump and the trump
administration with regard to
interventionism in the economy
particularly in these areas he he
suggested he was going to bring back a
lot of manufacturing jobs
uh there have been some manufacturing
jobs that have been added although
not not a huge number and not in
specific places
and that's where i started i sort of
start to get dicey
uh on the proposition that the
government has the capacity or or should
be engaging in a sort of
redistributionism
from consumers to particular producers
in certain areas
uh and uh and i guess my biggest
question when it comes to this sort of
stuff
is whether there's a promise that can
even be fulfilled meaning that
if you look at the history of american
economics i mean the fact is that
the manufacturing base driven by the
united states particularly in the 50s
and 60s was almost directly
as a result of the fact that the rest of
the world was rubble i mean after world
war ii we were the only untouched major
industrial nation
on planet earth and then we proceeded to
blow out our budgets
on massive union contracts that would
eventually bankrupt most of the audio
auto manufacturers in the 70s and 80s
making us nearly uncompetitive on the
world stage before regulatory cuts and
before de-unionization
and so a lot of the things that we love
about the 50s and 60s and we suggest
they're a product of the american system
actually may be products of the fact
that no other
industrialized country was capable of
producing at that point and we got
bloated and inefficient
and then we were forced back into more
efficiency that required industrial
scale back in the 70s and 80s
yeah there's a fair critique here um
that that i'll
i'll sort of agree with and then and
then try to maybe encourage
you know you and the listeners to sort
of think about this in a slightly
different way
so on the one hand you're absolutely
right the 50s and 60s are probably never
coming back
they were the consequence of a very
particular moment in history
and it's it's hard to imagine that level
of manufacturing power relative to the
rest of the world
uh so that's fair um on the other hand i
think the story
of american economic development has not
been primarily one of you know
the the the sort of the market pushing
and turning these things
uh on in its own way in other words um
you know one way of understanding the
50s and 60s is just like
america was the only place to do
business and therefore that was the
place to do business
but i think if you take sort of a longer
view of american history
we always had a very strong
developmentalist mindset it wasn't
anti-market it's sort of what's
interesting is it was
almost in some ways hyper commercial if
you talk about alexander hamilton or
henry clay or abraham lincoln
these were all people who did not
necessarily just want to protect the old
industries and i
sort of i imagine you feel like this i
certainly think you know some of the
industries are just going to die away
right some of them are not going to be
economically viable you can't save every
manufacturing job that's out there but
we also have this very discreet
idea that while the government shouldn't
be controlling the american economy
we should have as a policy consensus a
view about what we want the economy to
be
what we want the market to be able to
produce and to
put a little bit of a thumb on the scale
to make that possible
so you know in the in the early 20th
century that was a manufacturing thing
in the late 19th century that was
primarily an infrastructure development
thing but certainly the steam engine
was a very important piece of this you
know in the last 50 or 60 years we have
had specifically an american economic
policy around
two core industries not only two core
industries but two core industries stand
out
one is information technology aggressive
government policy to try to make us the
information technology leader of the
world
and two around biopharmaceutical
development which has been a little bit
more implicit
because the american economy is
basically the only place where you can
get
uh monopoly rents for developing new
drugs which is why so much of the
biopharmaceutical innovation happens
here
and i think that when i think about
economic development in the context of
american history
that's sort of more where i wish we
would go call it export promotion more
than import substitution i think that
you have to do some import substitution
so that the chinese don't just sort of
undercut
all of your manufacturing workforce with
slave wages among the uyghurs
but you what i really would love us to
do is have a theory
as a society of like where do we want
the economy to go okay we have a view
about information technology we have a
view about biopharmaceuticals
and you're not going to have the
government creating these industries
you're not going to have the government
i think intervening
intervening a ton of these industries
but it at least should have a discrete
view about what it wants to promote
where it's going to spend research and
development dollars
how it's going to sort of you know maybe
protect its nascent industries from
foreign competition
and that's just what we've sort of lost
and it's an interesting historical
question about why we lost it
and to go back to your point about the
50s and 60s which i think is largely
correct
there's a way in which we lost it
because we were so powerful
right in the 50s and 60s we didn't have
to think about
a national economic policy in any way we
just did
everything because we had the best
workforce we had the only economy that
hadn't been destroyed
the only advanced economy that hadn't
been destroyed and i would love to
actually
have us get back to a world where we
recognized like
you know like hamilton like clay like
lincoln
that we're in a national and an
international economic competition with
other countries
we can't just ignore that fact and we
need to actually pursue the industries
of the future that we think are viable
i think that's just been missing because
american policy makers didn't have to
think about it for 50 or 60 years
so in a second i want to ask you how we
draw the line between that and how we
prevent that from sliding
into sort of the government runs the
economy the government picks winners and
losers mentality that we see on the
other side of the political aisle
i'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about your internet
security
if you have ever had your information
hacked or stolen it is no fun
at all i've had my credit card stolen a
couple of times it is just
terrible you should care about
encrypting your data and here's the
thing it's easy for hackers to bypass
wi-fi security and steal that
information they'll exploit flaws like
crack that's crack with a k in case you
want to google it
that's why i use expressvpn to stay
secure online it's hard to know whether
your device or network is actually
vulnerable if you ever use a wi-fi at a
hotel or a shopping mall or a coffee
shop you're sending data over an open
network meaning no
encryption at all the best way to ensure
all of your data is encrypted and can't
be read by hackers
use expressvpn just download the
expressvpn app on your computer or
smartphone tap one button to secure 100
of your network data
and then just use the internet the way
you normally would expressvpn
it's incredibly reliable it's the
fastest vpn service i've tried they're
rated the world's number one vpn
provider by review sites like techradar
and cnet as well so
if you want the best in online security
and privacy protection head on over to
expressvpn.com for three extra months
free with a one year package
protect your internet today with the vpn
i trust to keep my data safe go to
expressvpn.com
ben to get started again that's
ben alrighty so one of the questions i
had when i when i had oren kass on the
program
was how we don't slide from basically
sort of tucker carlson's point of view
on economics to bernie sanders point of
view on
on economics um and uh tucker's actually
been rather unclear about this i asked
tucker this directly and he said well i
kind of agree with bernie sanders on a
lot of this sort of stuff
in fact tucker has uh you know praised
elizabeth warren's economic plans
in the past and it seems like um not
even necessarily a slippery slope but
uh in in exactitude of principle uh how
do we how do we prevent
a principle you know suggesting that we
should be able to forward particular
industries or pick the direction of the
economy
uh from the wholesale picking winners
and losers the government decides which
industries
ought to thrive in which industries
ought not to how do we how do we
distinguish between those two proposals
because
as we know the democratic party for
example right now is pushing
pretty hard in the direction of we're
going to spend every available dollar in
dollars that are not available
on the development of quote unquote
green technologies for which there is no
actual
record of success at this point so how
do we prevent the cylindring of the
american economy along these lines
well you know one thing i'll say about
tucker and oren in particular because i
think i think they're they're very
aggressive on this point
is there there's this weird
meta-narrative within the american right
that i think they're very explicitly
trying to to push on
and to try to rip the band-aid off a
little bit so i i don't think that
tucker's economic views are the same as
bernie sanders
uh maybe i'm wrong on that but i do
think what he is trying to get folks to
think about
is let's like let's stop with that part
of our brain that says we're not allowed
to go there because we're conservatives
let's actually like figure out
what's in the best interest of the
american nation the american worker and
let's just figure that out from there
and so
i sort of see his his his ambition there
not so much as
having the same economic policies as
bernie sanders but
moore is saying we need to stop with
that part of our conservative brain
that immediately reacts to everything
that reeks of government
as this is bad because it's government
um
and and i think that's i think that's a
useful corrective because i think you
know i think basically what's happened
is that a lot of
you know wisdom from the 60s 70s and 80s
is ossified into a little bit of a dogma
and to the extent that people are
pushing back on that i tend to think
that's useful
to answer your specific question i mean
i i tend to think
that we're probably going down this road
or have gone down this road already
and to the extent conservatives sort of
evacuate the field we're just giving
this up to the left and
and what i mean is we have whether we
like it or not in
an american economic policy we had one
of the 50s we had one in the 60s we
we've had one every single year that
this
this republic has been in existence even
when the scope of the government was
much more limited as it was of course
in the late 18th and early 19th century
um
you know i mentioned earlier we have an
a pro it
pro software pro hardware economic
policy in this country right now
we have an economic policy that's been
very beneficial of course to the
technology giants in silicon valley
that's been very protective of their
particular ways of regulating content i
mean that didn't exist in a vacuum of
course
that's not the free market that's really
just a specific policy choice that we
made
and i happen to think it was maybe
defensible 30 years ago 10 years ago
even
it's less defensible today and so i i
think that what we have to recognize is
that at some level the american
government is going to be doing
something in the american economy
and we should have a discreet view about
what we want that to be
and we should be pushing back against
the excesses of the left which it's hard
to do
if your view is well the government
shouldn't be doing anything vis-a-vis
the economy which i'm not saying of
course is your view i don't want to
caricature it
but but i i think that's pretty close
actually i don't i think you're
caricaturing it
well but but but i i think i think that
basically
you know the government sets laws right
it says
contract laws it sets capital markets
laws right every single public company
is able to be a public company that's
shielded from liability which is of
course i think you can make a good
argument is not a free market
intervention
uh into our corporate law uh they are
able to access incredibly liquid capital
markets because of
policy choices that we have made as an
american economy that we want them to be
shielded from liability but also have
access to easy credit
uh easy debt and also um easy equity
financing
so i i guess my view on this is look we
have an economic policy whether we like
it or not
do we want that economic policy to
pursue
broad-based prosperity for the american
middle class and the american working
classes do we want it to be able to make
the types of things that allow that we
stay ahead of our economic competitors
especially
in asia or are we just going to sort of
say we don't want the government to do
that
even though the government is already
doing that effectively seeding the
ground to the left i i think that we
have to
accept that there's a role to play here
for us
even if we don't think there should be i
mean the reality of politics is that
there is
and i don't want the conservatives to
abandon the field so what's
funny about this conversation is the
conversat in this conversation i'm the
libertarian and uh and you are the
more interventionist if you look at the
reviews of hillbilly elegy
the book and now the movie uh it is
precisely the opposite so the critique
of the movie and
of the book from the left is of course
that it is a libertarian fable um
because your personal story to get back
to that
is growing up in these uh somewhat
impoverished circumstances although your
grandparents weren't weren't
poverty-stricken but your mom
obviously was uh and um and then moving
from that to
yale law school by essentially making
some difficult decisions on a personal
level to
uh to break with the past so maybe you
can talk a little bit about that
yeah it's always funny you know because
uh you've you've you're obviously a much
bigger political or public figure than i
am been
and um have been writing about this
stuff for much longer than i have
and to the extent that i've been in the
public eye at all you know if you go
back to national review articles that i
wrote in 2004 2015
you know my politics have always been a
little bit on this side of the
conservative divide right i'm a social
conservative
i'm certainly not what i would call an
interventionist but you know if we're
sort of
putting the the libertarian versus
intervention aside i'm more on the
intervention side
on some of these big questions and it's
funny that
the reaction to the book is to treat it
as sort of some libertarian manifesto
from the left
i even saw a movie review which is
hilarious that said that it was a
libertarian like a libertarian work of
art or something like that
and they meant that critically um which
i find just
so bizarre because to me you know people
have to be able to hold two thoughts in
their head at the same time
you can believe that people have very
tough circumstances and that we as a
society have a responsibility
to give opportunity and hope to people
no matter the circumstances they came
from and then on the other hand that
people still have some responsibility in
some personal agency despite
rough personal circumstances right um i
always felt and this is
probably one of the reasons
psychologically i started identifying
with the right from a very early age
is that even if i didn't necessarily
agree with the rights prescriptions on
everything i at least felt like
conservatives treated people like me as
if we were actual people
we weren't just hopeless victims um and
i always
hated how you know the left brought all
the sympathy right for people like me
they wanted to help us with this program
or that
and of course a lot of the programs that
are out there haven't done the job that
the left hoped that they would do
but just at a more fundamental emotional
psychological level
the lesson that the left tend to have
for people is like well you're a
hopeless victim
the only way that you're ever going to
have any any good opportunities
is for us to sort of come in like
saviors and fix your lives
and consequently even though they say
this explicitly it was implicit
you should just give up on yourself
right if you're a hopeless agent
or hopeless non-agent and you have no
real opportunity then why work hard why
try to build a good family for yourself
why do
why try to go and find a good job why
give back to your community if your
community is just this desolate place
that has no hope
and i always i always resisted that and
i resisted in the book and i certainly
resisted in in the way that i talk about
these things now
consequently i think people assume that
like i am or at least you know some
people
on the left assume that i'm a
libertarian um but
you know i i i'm not and i really am
frustrated by the fact that people on
the left
can't believe both the people have
agency
and also that people have disadvantage
both things can be true at the same time
you might my grandma like a lot of
people who grew up in in tough
circumstances i mean if you look at the
statistics most people who are in
poverty don't
don't vote or at least i shouldn't say
most but a lot of people who are in
poverty don't vote
my grandma i don't think ever voted for
a president her entire life but she was
like a classic blue dog union democrat
her husband voted for democrats she was
sort of on the side
of the democrats and if i had to guess
my grandma would have voted for bernie
sanders in 2016.
maybe she would have voted for trump in
the general election you know again she
didn't vote so it's always hard to tell
but the way that mammal talked about
some people in our community
would have other people calling her a
hyper libertarian right like it's it's a
fact
of working class life this is a
well-observed phenomenon
that people have sympathy with a lot of
their neighbors they recognize that a
lot of them have tough circumstances
but they also get pissed off at the
people who aren't making good decisions
right
and it's amazing that like your average
working class
democrat can hold both frustration at
some of their neighbors
sympathy with other of their neighbors
in their head at the same time i wish
the same was true of our elite media
environment but unfortunately it's not
so let's talk about the elite media
environment in the treatment of the book
so the book comes out in 2016. it sells
like hotcakes uh it becomes for a while
sort of the decoder ring
for for everybody uh particularly in the
media uh
to trump country the idea is that this
is uh sort of if you don't understand
anybody who voted for trump in the
middle of the country because
you literally have only flown over that
part of the country then this book is
going to help you understand
those folks uh and then almost just as
quickly
uh by by 2017 there is a turn in the
media where this book
becomes almost uh a terrible book all of
a sudden there is this kind of
revisionist history where the book
becomes bad uh in that kind of brief
span where it was the toast of the town
and the span where it became
uh burnable uh there was this moment
where hollywood was like you know what
this thing has sold three million copies
probably should make a movie out of it
um but i want to talk in just one second
with you about that term from
the book everybody should read to the
book nobody you should read uh we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about the importance of life
insurance
it is your responsibility to take care
of your family and what this means is
that you have to have
life insurance if you have dependence
god forbid something should happen to
you you need to make sure that your
family
doesn't lose all of their financial
support and this holiday season you're
already spending too much money so why
not get life insurance and not spend a
fortune
try policy genius policy genius combines
a cutting-edge insurance marketplace
with help from licensed experts to save
you time and save you money
right now you could save 50 or more by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade the
savings really do start to add up
here's how it works first head on over
to policygenius.com in minutes you can
work out how much coverage you need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price policy genius will
then compare policies
starting at as little as a bucket a
might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam and then once you
apply the policy genius team
handles all the rest the paperwork the
red tape and they work for you not the
insurance company so if you hit speed
bumps they'll take care of everything
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across over
1600 reviews
on trustpilot and google so if you have
loved ones who depend on your income
don't go into 2021 without life
insurance go to policygenius.com and get
started you could save 50
or more by comparing quotes and start
the new year with one less thing
to worry about policy genius when it
comes to insurance it is nice and
important to get it right
so let's talk about that uh that shift
so in 2016 everybody recommends this
book
uh oprah winfrey suggests that people
read the book a lot of people say that
you should read the book on the left and
it becomes
uh sort of a common area of agreement
that if you want to understand what
exactly is happening in from country
you have to read the book so number one
i want to ask you about
whether that is an accurate take like
whether this is whether it was really
about trump countries you mentioned
uh you know the politics in this area
are not quite
clear cut um and on those lines i want
to ask you also about whether just
the appeal of trump in general do you
think was more economic or was it more
cultural because i do get the feeling
that
a lot of trump is basically just a giant
middle finger to all of the people on
the coast who look at people in the
middle of the country
uh as rubes who can't handle their own
their own lives um and then i want to
get to you know that shift that happened
and why you think that happened why it
went from the book everybody should read
to the book that everybody should burn
yeah so so first on um
the trump country thing i mean i i
always felt a little bit weird because
people would ask me about these trump
voters
you know in a way that i imagine and
this is of course my like friends and
family
in a way that i imagine you know people
ask like jane goodall about like the
great apes right it was like you know
you've actually seen these people you've
seen them like pick bugs out of each
other's hair what are they like what do
they talk about
um so there was this sort of weird trump
country safari element to it
um which on the one hand i mean you know
sort of
everything i said is of course sort of
an implicit criticism of it but on the
on the one positive thing i'll say about
it is at least people were asking
questions right it caught a lot of
people off guard
they weren't appreciative of trump and
his appeal
and so i at least appreciate that people
were sort of trying to read books like
mine to understand
trump voters better i think that's
that's sort of good when you live in a
country with
of of people with different political
views um you know the
the thing that of course is ridiculous
about it is like trump's voting base i
mean he got
what 75 80 million votes in the last
election he got a lot of votes in 2016.
that's like a very complicated group of
people you can't just read one book to
understand them
though though certainly it is true that
trump
accelerated a trend that had been true
where the white working class became
more and more conservative more and more
republican
and so to the extent that people are
sort of trying to project you know white
working-class hillbilly elegy onto
something that's going on into broader
american politics
i don't think that's totally off-base
because of course that was happening
people were becoming more
sympathetic to the republican party
people like my grandma um
you know or people like my grandma i
should say
who were classic blue dog democrats who
started to evolve their politics
um uh you know that that's something i
certainly saw happen not with my grandma
because she was dead before
you know well before trump came on the
scene but certainly with people like
that
who were really you know really
attracted to trump into his message
um the the second element of this uh
which is
this question of why it shifted to
a very popular book to a very unpopular
book in the mainstream media something
that
you know i've thought a lot about i mean
i think
part of what happened is that people
recognized
like my own politics right like i don't
shy away from it and
you know there are ways in which i sort
of fit comfortably within the
conservative coalition in ways in which
i don't but like
i'm very clearly on the american right
and so i think that there was a little
bit of just
you know we're giving this conservative
too much air time and so let's let's
change that
i think the more fundamental thing is
that for a
few weeks maybe a few months there was
this sort of
empathetic moment in america right trump
had lost the election i remember i was
invited to write on the new york times
basically about
what sort of you know coastal america
had missed about
trump voters and you know people
published the columns that i wrote and
it was this really interesting moment of
empathy and then two things happened
right
first the russia thing happened right it
was like the reason
trump won went from because there were a
lot of really pissed off white
working-class voters
to because it was stolen by russia right
and i think because of that people were
just much less interested
in the types of people that i was
writing about in the book i think the
second thing that happened and this was
initially led by the academy
but it became very mainstream is that
trump voters are not
economically dispen dispossessed they're
not culturally
affected except for the fact
that they're racist and the reason they
voted for trump was because of racism
right
and you know i've spent a lot of time
trying to understand this academic
literature i mean typically what happens
is they'll call people
using some sort of opinion polling and
they'll rank them according to
their racial resentment score and then
they'll compare how likely are the
people who are most racially resentful
to vote for donald trump
but of course the way that they measure
racial resentment is by things like
you know they'll ask the question well
previous generations of americans like
irish and italian americans were able to
assimilate and join
uh the american family live the american
dream um
other generation mexicans or black
americans or whoever you know take your
pick of whatever identity group
they should be able to do the same thing
and of course what's crazy about
those poll responses is that if you ask
latinos and black people
they often score higher on those metrics
than white people do right so to the
extent that white people are like
racially resentful
then the same is true of like every
other group in the country and so there
was this weird way where
we created this bizarre way of measuring
racism
and then painted with this very broad
rush where now all trump voters are
racist
right and one of the things that bothers
me so much about this
is that you see that in the reaction to
hillbilly elegy the book and hillbilly
elegy of the movie it's like why are we
talking about these right white people
the reason they voted for trump is
because they're racist because they're
dumb because they're bad
we don't want to hear any more about
them and i again i think that's just a
terrible way to think about these issues
it's a terrible way to think about
your fellow countrymen and women um you
know the
the other thing that i'll say i think is
going on both in the appeal to trump but
also the
sort of the reaction to hillbilly elegy
or the white working class more broadly
is that there's this bizarre thing
that's going on with american language i
know you've sort of talked about this
written about this and thought about
this
but whether it's the the latinx or latin
next thing
whether it's sort of describing people
who talk about the american dream in a
favorable way as racist
there's this really strong divergence
between the way that college educated
americans talk about public life
and the way that everybody else talks
about public life and that divergence i
think
drives a lot of what you know attracts
people to trump i do think it's economic
and we can sort of get into that if
you'd like
but i think a lot of it is that donald
trump doesn't sound like a totally
disconnected
college professor when he talks about
issues of immigration
or race or economics like whatever the
case may be he doesn't sound
like a pointy-headed weirdo i mean i
just can't believe i and i didn't think
i didn't think this in like 2013 that
there was such a disconnect between the
way that human beings
talk on each side of our educational and
class divide
but now it's just bizarre it's turned up
to 11. and i think you know if the left
wants a bit of maybe unwelcome advice
if you actually want to win
non-college-educated white voters in the
heartland
the main thing it's not policy it's not
any particular issue
it's stop sounding like everything is an
academic sociology seminar because
people can listen to that and they go
this is weird i don't want any part of
it i i think that there's also an
element there of a certain sneering
that attaches and i think that that
became clearer with trump than it was
even with with mitt romney
it seems to me a lot of the trump
support is driven in a certain way
in direct opposition to the sort of
coalitional politics that barack obama
was building there was a lot of talk
uh in the early 2000s and then through
the obama coalition particularly in 2012
about the building of a new political
coalition that was going to be majority
minority
with sympathetic white voters and it was
going to overwhelm
the historically white and racist
american system uh
and i think a lot of white voters went
hold up that's that's not me and you're
talking about me in a way i don't like
and i'm going to react to that
and i'm especially going to react to
that because the way that you talk about
trump is the way you talk about me
you talk about mitt romney like he was a
disconnected ceo who liked to fire
people their wives would get cancer
and whether or not that's true i mean he
is a ceo type right i mean he's
president business in the lego movie
right i mean that's that's that's what
he is
but donald trump you know is is a deez
dozen dem
type in terms of how he speaks and the
way that you speak about him is exactly
the way you speak about me
right you call him an idiot you call him
a boar you suggest that he's a bulgarian
you suggest that he's a con man and a
grifter and that his sort of
gut level whatever you think of trump he
sort of does have the gut level
love for the country and love for the
flag regardless of what he thinks of
those things
on a philosophical level and i think a
lot of people reacted uh to
tr i i really think that trump's major
appeal more than anything else
is one is something that he has said
many times which is they don't hate you
because they hate me
they hate me because they hate you and i
think that's right for for so many
americans
yeah i think that's that's very smart
and
it's it extends like further
it's not just about criticism of them
personally which i do think a lot of
people feel
uh to their core it's also about the
things that they hold dear right
um th this wasn't true when bill clinton
was running for political office it
wasn't true by the way when barack obama
was running for political office
um i actually you know i i sort of one
of my favorite like lines to give in
speeches
is that i give a paraphrase line from a
barack obama speech in 2007 or 2008 when
he was running for president
where it's basically you know the quote
goes something like you know
i really don't like it when people bring
non-american flags to protests in
america when i see a guy waving a
mexican flag in american protest i get a
flash of resentment
and you know you give that speech to
college educated audiences in 2017
2018 and you see people shift in their
chairs they're like oh where is this
going this guy is a little uncomfortable
and then you say well barack obama said
that like you know eight years ago 10
years ago and they're like oh wow that's
that's surprising and it just goes to
show
how different it is that people are
talking about these issues but
to go back to this sort of people feel
insulted personally but they also feel
insulted i think about
core parts of their identity so my
grandparents again
classic blue dog democrats but like when
you talk to them about world war ii
and they were kids in world war ii like
you know my my grandma's
older siblings and her father uh were
were in the navy
my grandfather didn't fight in the war
he just missed the sort of age cut off i
think it was 16 when the war ended
they they get they would get like
teary-eyed right i mean it was this
incredibly
proud moment of american history and
that moment
was important to them as people right
their identity as americans
who felt their country was good was
really important to them
and of course there are all kinds of
things that america has done wrong you
sort of have to issue that caveat but
people like
you know they recognize that there are a
lot of things wrong with their family
they still love their family they still
think things are good
uh the the american nation is in a lot
of sense
a sort of extended family for a lot of
people they care about its history
they're proud of its history
and if your operating assumption as a
potential leader of american politics
is not that america's made some mistakes
but america is fundamentally terrible
then a lot of people are going to feel
personally insulted because america is
something they actually care about it's
not just fake
and i actually think that this is it
sort of reveals the cynicism of a lot of
our sort of leadership class in the
country
is i don't think that they were well
they were caught off guard
by the reaction that a lot of people had
to this because they really don't think
that patriotism is something that
folks actually feel right they think
it's all manufactured they think it's
all like
you know koch brothers or somebody
else's propaganda to make people feel
feel good about america but a lot of
people actually just feel good about
america because they care about it and
it's theirs and they love it
and if that feeling is genuine it's very
often i think foreign to a lot of folks
in america's leadership class
it is pretty incredible i was rereading
barack obama's speech at the 2004 dnc
and it is unrecognizable when you get to
barack obama 2012
it is just not recognizable his 2004
speech he talks about how in inner city
inner city communities kids need to be
taught that getting a good education is
not acting white which is something he
would
you know he he's repeated it maybe twice
since then and every time it's a major
headline
uh 2004 you go back and howard dean was
talking about how he wanted to be a
candidate for people with pickup
with confederate flags in the back of
their pickup trucks and everybody was
just like okay well that makes sense i
mean there are a lot of people like that
and now if you even mention the
confederate flag it's because you're a
vicious racist who wants to bring back
slavery
yeah i mean howard dean would be not
just banished from the democratic party
but from polite society
uh if he if he uttered that same thing
in 2020
and uh ag again yeah you're you're right
it shows just a fundamental disconnect
and
there there is something you know
there's something weird here going on
about the class dynamics that i haven't
quite teased apart and this is a little
bit of a detour but
you'll forgive me but you know i
remember when kevin hart
was basically kicked out of hosting the
oscars which of course i'm sure was a
big career moment would have brought him
a lot of
a lot of additional wealth and money so
it had a real economic effect on his
life
um and and basically it was for the sin
of
tweeting you know some things i forget
exactly even what he had tweeted
was in 2010 he tweeted something it was
some joke about how he didn't want his
son to be gay in 2010.
okay okay yeah and and i remember like
the reaction to that
revealed the way in which you're sort of
penalized again
for not adopting the vocabulary of
like modern 2020 professionally educated
america
um so so you know like people
joke about things in all kinds of ways
they're very often politically incorrect
uh people say hateful i mean i can't
imagine thank god facebook didn't exist
when i was 16 years old i'm sure that i
said a ton of stupid and hateful things
uh when i was 16 years old but you know
we don't want to live in a society where
being
not professionally educated and not
worrying about every word that comes out
of your mouth
mouth is effectively a barrier to
economic and social advancement and
that's kind of the society that we live
in
and i do think that a lot of of
working-class voters not just white
voters because of course a lot of
latinos and
and even black working-class voters
migrated to republicans in the last
election
i think that they sort of there's
something they recognize that this way
of talking
if it becomes a barrier to achievement
is just going to be really bad for them
and they're right
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that america
is always under constant threat this
nation has been confronted with
unprecedented perils edmund burke said
it all it takes for evil to prevail is
for good people to do nothing well if
you want to preserve america while we
still can
it's time to join amac that's the
association of mature american citizens
it's the fastest growing conservative
group
in the country joining amac will give
you access to money-saving benefits
cutting-edge news
and a great bi-monthly magazine more
importantly amac fights for you
there's a socialist storm a bruin if you
care about our future the way i do you
need to join amac today
over two million conservatives like you
like me have already joined amac stand
with us by joining right now just go to
amac dot u s slash shapiro that's amac
dot us slash shapiro the benefits of a
mac membership are great
the cause is even more important join
today at amac dot us slash shapiro the
country is always under threat you can
fight back by joining amac
amac.us shapiro again that's
dot us slash shapiro i think that
the backlash that started to materialize
with trump is certainly not going to end
with trump i mean
when you see how corporate america has
militarized i mean really militarized
on behalf of a sort of woke agenda the
nasdaq announced
this week that they were going to be uh
only listing companies
that in that increased diversity on on
their boards i mean
the the the takeover of corporate
america the the the establishment media
the social media companies that will now
quash free speech
mainstream stuff great example this week
was something that i think is a complete
disconnect for most americans
uh the the hollywood star uh ellen page
announced that she was trans and will
now be known as elliott page and every
single headline was elliott page
juno junostar announces he is
transgender
if you had no previous knowledge of what
was going on you have no idea what that
headline means
elliot page emerged today right i mean
like you literally have no you've never
heard of elliot page before
the juno star was ellen page and was a
woman what in the world are you talking
about but if you went on twitter and you
said ellen page is a woman
you would be hit across the across the
face with this with this
bizarre notion that you were a bad
person for acknowledging
a fact that happens to be biologically
true and also even according to elliot
page
was true as of seven minutes ago but
it's it's not just that we have to
violate the laws of biology we also have
to
violate the laws of physics and retro
and retconne this so that actually the
star of juno
was a transgender man named elliot page
i mean all of this i think creates a
disconnect in the minds of americans
uh with real consequences because the
elite the elitists in the society do
have consequences ready for people who
refuse to abide by these dictates
yeah that's right and the consequences
are very real and this is by the way
you know one of one of the pitches i
make to more you know to more
libertarian minded conservatives like
like yourself been
for for why we need to be a little bit
wary about the commercial
or the alliance that existed between the
right and commercial actors in our
society
is that you know for a long time
basically the dynamic
in american politics was the left owned
the culture
the right owned the money and the
commercial and corporate power and they
battled over political power
and one of the things that's happened is
that the right has now lost
one of those two spheres right we can
still win elections
but the both the culture and the
corporate leadership is now firmly
behind
uh firmly behind uh the the left
i i i saw this statistic recently um
that in the 19 i think in 1990 the
fortune 10 companies were all
led by republicans i think their ceos
were all republicans or maybe nine out
of ten
uh and in in 2020 the fortune 10 ceos
are
all democrats and so i do think that one
of the
important realizations that has to
happen for conservatives is like
we don't own the market anymore we don't
own the actors in the market anymore
they have sort of gone over to the other
side
and our politics has to adjust to that
fact but that's really the consequence
your point
you asked about consequences those are
the consequences that matter right
um yeah you might get you know beat up
on social media especially if you're
more of a public figure for saying you
voted for trump or saying you voted for
whatever republican candidate of the day
of the day is
but the thing that really bothers people
when i talk to friends who
you know maybe they voted for trump and
didn't tell people or they tried not to
be open about it
what they were worried about was not
criticism from their peers and their
neighbors it was
what they were worried about is they
might get fired yep and we are now
in that environment where uh people on
the right
really have to worry about what they're
saying especially if they're working for
the most elite
companies in the country you have to
worry about this less if you work at a
small manufacturer in southern ohio than
you do if you work at google of course
if you work at google you've really got
to worry
about what you say or you might lose
your job and um
you know that that strikes me as a
pretty unhealthy
absolutely um even if you're working at
a small company in southeastern ohio if
you go on twitter or facebook and you
say something
there's a high likelihood that
somebody's going to pick that up and
then call your boss
uh and that your your boss will be
inundated or that yelp will suddenly
review you as a racist business and your
boss is going to be forced to fire you
i mean the the sort of censorship regime
from the top is
is really pervasive and i think the
people on the left are underestimating
what the backlash is going to be and now
the question i think
between the two of us is actually not
really about that i think it's really
about what's the method of fighting it
i tend to think that that has to be
fought more on a cultural level as
opposed to
uh well what can even be done in the
political sphere i'm not sure what can
be done
in the political sphere to reverse that
i think that
in the end what what may have to happen
is that unfortunately we may break into
a country that basically has a
republican credit card company a
democratic credit card company and a
republican bank and a democratic bank
i worry about that especially you know
as you know i spend most of my day
investing in technology companies and
um you know certainly you talk to
companies that have more of a right of
center bent
and sometimes they'll say they're maybe
a little bit worried that for example
amazon web services or sort of critical
infrastructure component whether they're
going to be able to continue to host
their website
uh if this thing gets any worse i mean i
agree with you that we certainly have to
exercise cultural power but i also think
that
there are some basic policy assumptions
in the american regime that corporations
are going to be fundamentally neutral
right like maybe the ceo is going to say
what the ceo is going to say maybe there
will be some political donations
but i think there is an assumption of
neutrality like why do we offer all of
these protections to our companies
if not to sort of assume um or
or if they're not going to assume some
posture of neutrality
and so i do think that if if we continue
to go down this path
we're either going to have like you said
a left-wing economy and a right-wing
economy
or we're going to have to start actually
you know telling our
corporations like look if you want the
benefit of american limited liability
you have to show some neutrality right
if you want to continue to access
capital markets
you can't just fire republicans for
saying things that republicans believe
in
um and so i i'm willing to use not just
the cultural power but eventually
um the the legal and political power if
we have to use it
i mean it may eventually come to that
especially if what you're talking about
that my great fear of doing that of
course is that
any sword that is wielded by the
government can be wielded by either side
you're already seeing it wielded against
religious people particularly so if you
maintain neutrality in business and then
you have a religious business owner who
wants to actually
you know act religiously in their
business the government's already coming
after those folks maybe the eventuality
has already come
and left's already using the power and
there there is no neutral principle to
be upheld at this point and now it's
just
a sort of hobbesian war of all against
stalin which uh either we we establish
a strict neutral principle for every
company in america
including religious people and including
people who are on the far left
um because the left is simply not going
to leave it alone that's definitely a
possibility
yeah there is there is a scary way
sometimes in which the slippery slopes
we seem to be already on them or even at
the bottom if that's true
then you know i i think our our like
like i mentioned with tucker earlier i
think our policy aperture has to widen a
little bit
so let's talk about the movie so
obviously we're talking today because
the movie
finally has come out in 2020 the
production process and the length of it
obviously did not benefit
uh the critics because if this movie had
come out in 2016 immediately upon the
the success of the book
i would have been 99 on rotten tomatoes
right now it currently ranks about 27
on rotten tomatoes and i'm sure after
they uh they've now announced that
rotten tomatoes they're going to be
having a top critics
uh feature as well so presumably among
the top critics it is it
currently negative 37 um but
the the public approval of the film
maintains the the kind of fan rating of
the film
is up in the 80s there's this huge
60-point gap between what the critics
think
and what the public thinks in terms of
approving uh the film yeah so
as somebody who's seen the film and the
film is quite good
i can say this is really apolitical all
of the politics that we have discussed
this entire this entire episode do not
come up
virtually at all in the film when i say
virtually i mean i don't even think
virtually like at all in the film it's
an extraordinarily
a political film it is very personalized
ron howard uh i think
uh actually stripped as much politics as
could be stripped out of the story out
of the story and tried to focus in
specifically on the family story uh and
yet people decided to read the politics
in there anyway what do you make of the
critical response
well it definitely shows a real
disconnect and i i worry about that
because
uh you know you don't want to have a
media that's so separate from the rest
of the country right
we actually want to share a country
together charles murray has written
about this very very effectively
uh that if you have a group of people
who set the tone of the conversation who
are so disconnected from the people who
are actually viewing films viewing tv
shows
then it's just another wedge that sort
of exists between the broad
population in the country and everybody
else that's just not not a good thing
i do think it's political i think you
know i like the movie i'm happy with
what ron did it obviously our politics
aren't the same but i think he just
wanted to make
an empathetic family drama about
problems you know addiction family chaos
trauma
that are unfortunately all too common in
the country especially in the part of
the country that i call home
so i i think he did a good job with it
and i hope people will give
um give it give it give it a chance you
know the politics of it are just bizarre
you know i mentioned somebody called it
a libertarian fantasy or something not
not the book the movie
to me there are two even plausibly
political
things in the entire movie so one of
them is that the book sort of highlights
that mama when she was raising me didn't
have a lot of money and this is true to
the actual real life characters
i was actually struggling to pay for
some of her health care right now you
could take a number of different policy
outcomes from that but certainly that's
not like a libertarian fantasy to sort
of talk about the fact that people have
trouble paying for their health care you
know
i think i think you could sort of again
go into different directions with that
but
that's not i think a fair
characterization to call it libertarian
fantasy and then the other thing
is that she does emphasize a couple of
times with me personally and other
characters in the movie my mamaw
emphasizes
look this is not easy but you've got to
do the right thing anyway you've got to
try to make the right decisions even if
our lives haven't been totally easy and
again
i think that that message of empowerment
uh
i understand now that people believe
that's political but i think it's
depressing because
um i know a lot of people who come from
very rough circumstances who are
democrats
and they think a message of empowerment
is actually valuable so it's unfortunate
that the
the left-wing critics haven't agreed so
in just a second i want to ask
jd vance a few final questions starting
with places where the movie is different
from his life if you'd like to hear
jd vance's answers you have to be a
daily wire member head on over to
dailywire.com click join you can hear
the rest
of our conversation over there well jd
vans really appreciate your time
everybody should go check out jd's
best-selling book first hillbilly elegy
and then watch the brand new film
adaptation on netflix jd really
appreciate the time
thanks man good to talk with you
[Music]
this episode of the sunday special was
our last for 2020. we will have new
episodes coming out in 2021
but we are trying a new format episodes
aren't going to be released on a
schedule
instead we're going to record them as we
find the right guests and the right
topics to discuss the best of the best
we've had such an amazing lineup of
guests through the past few seasons and
we are excited to level up our approach
with timely and relevant interviews that
continue to push daily wire
into the mainstream conversation have a
wonderful christmas and we'll see you
next year
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowski
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina hair and makeup is by
nika geneva
title graphics are by cynthia angulo the
ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2020.